entreprises commerces restaurants à
nouveau ouvert à nouméa la vie commence
à reprendre son cours normal
le territoire à mort ce sont des
confinement une satisfaction pour les
restaurateurs qui doivent tout de même
adapter leur façon de travailler
on a donc prévu de candiac et les
clients s'asseoir l'espace d'une table
entre chaque entre chatrian ce qui fait
à peu près de mettre des espaces on a
prévu également de servir avec nos gants
avec nos masques et on a également dû
gel hydroalcoolique que les coûts et en
métro quand ils arrivent au sein
d'établissements voilà et on cuisine on
a effectivement prévu d'avoir le moindre
échange possible avec la clientèle avec
seulement 18 cas de corona virus rouge
foncé et l'absence de nouvelles
contaminations depuis le 4 avril
les autorités de l'archipel du pacifique
ont donc annoncé cette levée progressive
du confinement
elle concernera dès mercredi les
établissements scolaires situés dans la
province sud de l'île salle de classe
désinfecter distribution de gel hydro
alcoolique au lycée do kamo tout est
déjà prêt pour l'arrivée d'une partie
des élèves n'auront que la moitié de
l'effectif c'est à dire que chaque
classe a été divisé en deux groupes
nous mettons en place tout ce qui est
mesure de distanciation donc dans les
classes les élèves seront uniquement à
un parent par tap de deux élèves pareil
aussi dans la cour de récréation nous
allons veiller à ce qu'il n'y ait aucun
vrai rassemblement des consignes
strictes
pourtant la rentrée des classes ne fait
pas l'unanimité en nouvelle calédonie
les organisations syndicales ainsi que
des membres de la communauté kanak
alerte sur les risques d'un
déconfinement trop hâtif dans la
province indépendantistes au nord de
l'île
les établissements ne rouvriront pas
avant le 4 mai la question des versets
de la sécurité sanitaire de nos enfants
doit être
doit être complètement garanti ce qui à
l'heure actuelle n'est pas du tout le
cas
on sait bien que le risque zéro n'existe
pas mais pour nous il faut des
conditions optimales au niveau sanitaire
pour que nos enfants les parents n'est
pas la boule droit qu'en envoyant leurs
enfants à l'école ils veulent ouvrir les
écoles pour ce soit cohérent avec les
entreprises aussi et que les parents
autant de travailler pour ramener
l'économie
maintenant nous ce qu'on demande c'est
de laisser les secteurs essentiels pour
que l'économie continue de tourner et
puis que les citoyens de base mécanique
puis se continue à avoir lors le revivre
ce soit côté frais toi là on a on a
salué les gens qui devraient continuer à
travailler d avis que partage le sénat
coutumier où siègent les représentants
des chefferies traditionnelles kanak
le conseil préconise même un confinement
généralisée jusqu'à la fin du mois
d'avril